[Music]
so Stalin's terror the economic failure
of the Soviet Union the fall of the
Berlin Wall and the popular uprisings
across Eastern Europe they did appear to
have buried socialism but now a new
generation is calling for radical change
so can this surge of idealism create a
new political theory that will avoid the
errors of the past and finally live on
the promises of salute of socialist
thought or do we risk having to learn
the very painful lessons of the past all
over again well I'm delighted to be
hosting such a distinguished panel to
discuss this burning issue so on my far
left we have Angela Eagle my far left as
we said it all depends on your
perspective so your guys may think of
her as on the right she is the only
person on the stage who's actually had
experience of government so this is this
is you know real practical politics
getting things done on my immediate left
John Landsman active in radical politics
in the 80s went a bit quiet under New
Labour returned with a vengeance with
momentum helping and when continuing to
support Jeremy Corbyn we have the
distinguished writer broadcast David
Iran a [ __ ] who spent his childhood
years in the warm embrace of the
Communist Party and and no doubt but now
works for Rupert Murdoch's times John
you're perhaps most visibly engaged in
trying to deliver a new kind of
socialism is it going to work this time
can we avoid the errors of the past well
first of all I think that what we saw
with the election of Jeremy Corbyn which
surprised everybody including me and
most most of all that's Jeremy Corbyn
was an upsurge completely spontaneous I
wish I could say I organized it but I
didn't it was spontaneous and it was an
upsurge of hope and optimism and that
was because
people were hearing things that they
hadn't heard before or hadn't heard for
a long time that that made clear that
the politics of neoliberalism and
austerity were a choice and not a an
inevitability and they saw an
alternative and that's what gave them
hope and you know you could see that in
how the camp how the campaign grew how
it acquired momentum you know we start
we book small holes in the beginning of
the campaign they got filled up and
eventually we made videos of the queues
that went around the blocks and it was
new because when Jeremy was asked
questions against the other three
candidates in the contest the other
three candidates were evasive and Jeremy
answered the questions directly now I
think that is a real positive I think
also it was very rapidly Blair even
before the end of that a leadership
contest that you know the left succeeded
in in in achieving at least at some
level the intellectual defeat of
neoliberalism in that in that Theresa
May and the Taurus changed their
language in the discourse about about
austerity and you know eventually she
parked her tanks on our lawn even it
didn't have they didn't have much
firepower and I think the left is
capable of learning the lessons of the
past I think we are forging a new
politics now I think the young people
who come in you know a lot of the people
who joined the Labour Party and the
members of the Labour Party trebled in
that campaign are people who weren't
born you know when when this when the
Soviet Union collapsed or weren't old
enough to remember it I think the the
you know the the left was damaged by the
by what by the experiences and
and the and the failures of communism
and but I think we are now forging a new
politics thank you very much Angela was
it was notable after the fall of the
wall that the thinking all seemed to
move to the right you know the think
tanks that the the influence of for
instance the the the new right think
tanks in the United States which is now
entered mentally in politics the Left
seemed completely discombobulated after
after the collapse of the old Soviet
Soviet model and and you know we had
this triumphalism of the of the new
right in the States you've now written a
book about those ideas you you seem to
be arguing that this is a moment they
can be combatted so I actually would
like to start off by saying that I don't
regard the tradition that I've been in
for all my life the Labour Party in
Britain as having anything to do with
Stalin ISM or what happened in the
Soviet Union I'm a Democratic Socialist
and I think that the vision that I have
it is a five values for the way that we
renew socialism in our country and those
values in no particular order are
liberty democracy equality cooperation
and internationalism and I don't think
Stalinism had a lot to do with any of
that and so I think the only future for
socialism is as Democratic socialists
within a democratic system arguing that
what I call in the book not
neoliberalism because that liberalism
sounds like a good thing I argue in the
book that we've suffered from forty
years of market fundamentalism a
fundamentalist belief that markets are
the only way to make any decision that
the price mechanism is the only way to
choose any priority and that somehow you
cannot have the collective intervention
via an empowering state to create
society that's more civilized where
people have more opportunities that's
fairer that achieves liberation for
women for people with disabilities for
that avoid prejudice and discrimination
against people who were in the minority
the kind of society that I've always
wanted to build as a socialist so I
think we have to get away from this idea
that there's an authoritarian
anti-democratic democratic centralist
sort of Russian communists way to Annie
Ivana that's always been a dead end and
when the Berlin Wall fell that was the
end of that kind of communistic view in
my view and so we've got to forge a
different way and that's about how we
transform a society that is a democracy
with a functioning market by putting the
market in its proper place and asserting
the primacy of a collective vision of
the direction we want our societies
going
David you were well schooled in in the
socialism of the past in in your youth
do you see do you see a form of idealism
around you that that is going to deliver
on those promises I want to make a
distinction really between I John made a
good speech talking about optimism that
this is actually a discussion about
socialism and the one thing I think I
probably did learn as a kind of chord
young Marxist was the need to actually
be concrete about the thing it is that
you're talking about so what do we
actually mean by the word socialist what
is it I was brought up to believe and I
think John probably was too that
socialism was a distinct system from
capitalism it's not capitalism it's
socialism and that's why that the
original well the love for it after 1918
that Clause four of the Labour Party
Constitution called for effectively the
common ownership of the means of
production distribution and exchange it
didn't make any qualification about it
what it was effectively was saying was
we should own everything in common and
as one of the problems that we
discovered was if we are we who are the
we that has the ownership how do we
organize that ownership that we all have
of everything and and in the absence of
significant private property and the
profit motive and so one of the problems
that you have is that when you talk
about socialism so for instance I don't
think there is when when when answer
talks about Democratic station and I
have very great respect for her
political position I don't think it's
socialist I think it's capitalist I
think managed capitalist a capitalism is
incredibly varied and is very incredibly
plastic partially because of the things
that it embodies and what she's talking
about is a modified form of capitalism
as almost all forms of capitalism are in
fact modified isn't
socialism it could very well be
democratic she certainly is a Democrat
and and her instincts are her instinct
our instincts are right
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you